literally just made another video public
and then I come to find out that right
when I make it public oh this actually
came out a little bit of yawn I
completely didn't notice it Marvel's
spider-man Miles Morales announcement
trailer for the PS 5 bet your ass in the
beginning a PS 5 I actually just beat
spider-man on the ps4 maybe two months
ago loved the game freaking loved the
hell out of that game in almost every
day of game in front of mine that I
catch up with it's one of the first
things they bring on me everybody I
remind you to please fireman yet John
hasn't played the game yet so I didn't
want to you know want to make just in
case didn't want anything to be spoiled
for him and based off of the way how
that one ended obviously we beginning
Miles Morales doing some spider-man
action this time around so yeah let's
just see what's in store baby
check out these ps5 graphics
[Music]
a hero's just someone who doesn't give
up your dad said he was right
now it's your turn you'll be a hero our
lives so excited
[Music]
Wow
Oh
be greater with greater responsible no
no with greater power comes greater
response here first off is this like the
official sequel to it is it going to be
called a Spider Man Miles Morales is
that what this title will be is this
gonna be like a dlc version because that
can open up a whole can of worms here
the way how that dialogue was formed at
the beginning with Peter Parker there it
sounds like Peters probably dead not
that there was anything to allude to
that at the end of the first game with
this one and the fact that there's that
dialogue there and then also factoring
in the comics you know it's like wait a
minute
did they just kill off Peter Parker for
the sequel there's no confirmation here
I feel like I'm led to believe that that
he's most likely not gonna be here which
would be a bummer but it's a comic book
video game they'll find some way to
bring him back maybe this will actually
open up some type of crazy spider verse
door into the video games spider-man
spider version to the video games we'll
get something like that along the way I
mean I'd be pretty bummed if you don't
get out like I love the Peter Parker
portrayal in the first game it would be
really heartbreaking for that to happen
I'm all on board for the Mazzarella
scare achter and I love seeing the
stealth suit moment that was really
badass and I loved the final moment with
the blast coming from his hands I look
great it looks like it's taking on a
character halo in that moment I'm
excited to see who all the other
villains are they're gonna be there the
graphics undoubtedly look incredible but
yeah I haven't looked up any like
backstory I don't know what announcement
there was preceding the debut of this
trailer right now with all the footage
we're getting it seems like that this is
the actual sequel to the game the
heavily anticipated spider-man sequel
and this was not the direction I would
expect it to go so maybe it's some
spin-off game maybe some DLC version if
you guys happen to know please let me
know in the comments is I'd love to get
some clarity on that but if Peter
Parker's dead maybe it's just temporary
so we can get on the Miles Morales train
it sort of feels like that they're
trying to match this a little bit more
akin to the mozzarella's from the
spider-man to the spider verse movie I
mean even having the song that was
playing over it just made me think of
into the spider verse anyway guys what
did I miss in this trailer
any bit of clarity you can give me would
love to hear it if there's any specific
GameTrailers coming out right now that
you'd like us to check out let me know
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell last but not least J
and Valente dude I have no idea what to
say I don't know where the hell are you
[ __ ] you keep like disappeared off of
the face of the planet man we used to
talk all the time I would spend at least
20 minutes every time replying you and
now I don't know where you are I mean
you're still pledged which we really
appreciate but the same time kind of
worried I mean last time we talked
Denzel you're in the best of spirits now
I haven't heard from you in forever once
in a while you'll hit the like button on
something you haven't talked to me so
maybe you like the content but you don't
like me as an individual which is OK my
girlfriend feels the same way maybe you
should date her Missy buddy just let me
know what's up hopefully doing an actual
video calling you out will get you to
the earth on blood